[Music]
and it is an element we share the
European values that made up the Europ
an project solidarity, diversity, justi
e and tolerance today more neces
ary than ever parla
ent is involved is already very much alive sport
legislation on the Europ
an social pillar is essential in terms
of equality between men and women and the
elimination of the salary gap is
fundamental and also everything that has
to do with the just transition with the
ecological transition and with the fight
against climate change
camps tris exception
we will never share spaces of
understanding with those who  They have come to
the European Parliament to destroy the
European project with the rest of the
political forces. We must understand each other
above all, we will understand each other with the
progressive and pro-European political forces,
understanding the difference in
position but also the need to
walk in the same direction
[Music]